[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen an diesem
mittwoch an meiner seite ist für den
sport norbert lehmann sogenannte von mir
und das sind unsere themen heute
endlich in sicherheit das erste flugzeug
mit über 100 menschen aus afghanistan
landet in deutschland
hilfe für den wiederaufbau für die
schäden in den hochwassergebieten
beschließt das kabinett einen 30
milliarden euro vor
und erster titel für nagelsmann der fc
bayern gewinnt den supercup gegen
borussia babett
endlich gelingt es mehr menschen aus
afghanistan heraus zu holen die
internationale luftbrücke steht auch die
bundeswehr ist beteiligt bis jetzt
konnte die luftwaffe mit mehreren flügen
etwa 670 menschen aus kabul nach
taschkent aus fliegen sagt das
verteidigungsministerium von dort geht
es weiter nach deutschland in der nacht
landete eine erste maschine in frankfurt
am main luton leyen muss berichtet um
kurz vor 4 heute früh landet die
lufthansa-maschine aus taschkent in
frankfurt viele der 130 menschen an bord
haben furchtbares erlebt auch mohammad
hier ist endlich in sicherheit die ganze
schüsse sind noch ein ohr die man vom
flughafen gehört hat und um das zu
verarbeiten braucht man wirklich paar
tage
vanessa frey sie ist wieder zu hause im
rhein-main-gebiet sie war auf einer
hochzeitsfeier in afghanistan tage lang
hoffte sie auf nachricht aus dem
auswärtigen amt
jede stunde habe ich gemacht auf eine
mail
aufatmen bei familie aus dem hessischen
fulda dass sie es überhaupt auf den
abgesperrten flughafen schafften
verdanken sie einem mitfühlenden
us-soldaten also wenn man hat oder nicht
hat von stehen die amis und sagen das
sogar seine art und der eine amerikaner
hatte mitleid und aus mitleid hat er uns
raus rein gelassen weil er gemerkt habe
beide kinder waren einfach für
ängstliche wir hatten angst und haben
geweint die ersten afghanischen
ortskräfte werden morgen in dieser
erstaufnahmestelle in brandenburg
erwartet ihre guten sprachkenntnisse
dürften vieles erleichtern ich glaube
dass diejenigen die mit den deutschen
bundeswehrkräften zusammengearbeitet
haben sicher einen großen vorteil der
integration
die ortskräfte und ihre familien
absolvieren hier einen corona test und
bekommen kleidung sowie medizinische
hilfe drei bis vier tage später werden
sie auf andere bundesländer verteilt
unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf hat
kontakt zu menschen die seit tagen
verzweifelt versuchen das land zu
verlassen katrin was erzählen sie dass
sie immer wieder versuchen am flughafen
in das gelände zu kommen das sie
abgewiesen werden ich habe ganz engen
kontakt mit einer familie die ich auch
sehr gut kenne die haben drei kleine
kinder die haben sich jetzt schon zum
dritten mal auf den weg zum flughafen
gemacht werden von einem geht ans andere
weitergeleitet sind überglücklich dass
es bis dahin geschafft haben wir haben
heute kontakt gehalten da hat er mir
eine nachricht geschickt und gesagt sie
sind amerikaner aber die lassen mich
nicht rein dann hat man versucht kontakt
zu der bundeswehr herzustellen zu
deutschen das war nicht möglich der
kontakt ist dann wieder abgebrochen das
sind wirklich dramatische situationen
die sich da abspielen für die menschen
ist das ganz schrecklich immer wieder
mit der neuen hoffnung an den flughafen
zu gehen aber da nicht weiter zu kommen
das ist wirkt doch sehr unkoordiniert
wenn man das hier aus der ferne verfolgt
und das sind verzweifelte szenen
ich habe auch kontakt zu charivari einer
ziemlich bekannten afghanischen
politikerin die er noch gestern einen
appell an die welt gerichtet hatte und
gesagt hat die taliban werden kommen und
werden holen und mich töten auch sie hat
heute den ganzen tag am flughafen auf
ausgeharrt ist hin und her geschickt
wurden und vor einer stunde habe ich die
nachricht bekommen sie sitzt auf dem
kläger nach deutschland dankeschön
katrin eigener für diese schilderung
in den vergangenen 24 stunden sollen
insgesamt 5000 menschen mit
militärschlägen aus kabul evakuiert
worden sein über die lage am flughafen
und die lage im land drei tage nach der
machtübernahme der taliban berichtet lag
wallbott in kabul starten und landen
wieder zahlreiche militärtransporter
aber die lage rund um den flughafen ist
nach wie vor chaotisch tausende afghanen
versuchen weiter auf das gelände zu
gelangen der zugang wird von us soldaten
bewacht die auch waren schüsse abfeuern
in sozialen medien werden bilder von
verzweifelten frauen verbreitet die um
einlass bitten eine niederländische
maschine musste ohne passagiere
abfliegen weil die familien vor den
toren festhängen und an den straßenzügen
zum flughafen haben taliban kräfte
kontrollpunkte eingerichtet in anderen
vierteln der hauptstadt herrscht mehr
ruhe die menschen klagen aber über
rasant steigende preise
ein sack mehl kostet jetzt umgerechnet
20 dollar ein kanister öl 14 dollar dass
es zu viel
im südafghanischen kandahar traf
unterdessen der politische führer der
taliban mullah baradar mit einem
militärflugzeug aus katar ein baradar
gilt als möglicher chef einer
übergangsregierung
über deren bildung berieten in kabul
führende taliban mit ex präsident karzai
sowie den bisherigen regierungschef
abdullah im ostafghanischen jalalabad
kam es zu schweren protesten gegen die
machtübernahme der taliban
demonstranten trugen einen tag vor dem
unabhängigkeitstag jubelnd die
afghanische flagge durch die straßen die
die taliban überall entfernt hatten
taliban- kräfte eröffneten das feuer auf
die menge augenzeugen berichten von
mindestens drei toten und einem dutzend
verletzten
die bundesregierung und den
nachrichtendienste haben die lage in
afghanistan völlig falsch eingeschätzt
das hat außenminister maß schon
vorgestern zug gegeben heute mussten ehe
und die verteidigungsministerin sich in
bundestagsausschüssen rechtfertigen die
opposition wirft der regierung komplett
versagen vor und fordert konsequenzen
aus berlin thomas reichert die
verteidigungsministerin hat sich
aufgeschrieben was sie öffentlich sagen
will an diesem mittag soll der
bundeswehr mission wie es sie noch nie
gegeben hat sie liest von einem zettel
fragen zur evakuierungs mission zu ihrer
verantwortung aber beantwortet sie als
paar nicht
es ist ganz klar die bundeswehr wird so
lange wie möglich so schnell wie möglich
so viele menschen wie möglich dort
rausholen umso heftiger ist im
verteidigungsausschuss die kritik der
opposition daran dass die bundeswehr
nicht schnell genug losgeschickt wurde
an der viel zu späten hilfe für die
ortskräfte
dieses zögern dieses bürokratische
kleinen kleinen zwischen verschiedenen
ministerien das kann und ich befürchte
das wird am ende des tages menschenleben
kosten in der tat werden wir danach
politisch das aufarbeiten und ich
schließe nicht aus dass dann auch für
den ein oder anderen minister und die
ministerin das ende eingeläutet wird am
morgen hatte das kabinett beschlossen
was tatsächlich schon passiert die
bewaffnete evakuierung mit bis zu 600
bundeswehrsoldaten aus afghanistan
der bundestag muss dem nachträglich zu
stimmen jetzt herrscht also alle nach
dem mars kramp karrenbauer seehofer über
wochen so berichten insider das problem
nicht sehen wollten es ist ein
menschliches drama und katastrophe es
ist eine politische
katastrophe ist ein moralisches
scheitern des westen des westens
das auswärtige amt hat nun sein
afghanistan-beauftragten nach dover
geschickt doch die verhandlungen mit den
taliban dort werden schwierig wir haben
derzeit keine belastbaren sicherheits zu
sagen dass die taliban afghanische
staatsangehörige frei zum botschaft zu
flughafen passieren lassen zwei weitere
flüge soll es heute noch geben völlig
unklar wie viele es überhaupt zum
flughafen von kabul zu den erretten den
maschinen schaffen werden und
es gibt neue vorwürfe theo koll in
berlin danach hat bürokratie die rettung
von 300 kräften in masar i scharif
verhindert ja und zwar schon ende juni
das verteidigungsministerium hat uns
heute bestätigt dass schon am 25 juni
afghanische kräfte und ihre familien aus
dem hauptstützpunkt der bundeswehr in
masar i scharif ausgeflogen werden
sollten dafür waren sogar schon zwei
spanische charterflugzeuge organisiert
worden damit hätte man wenige tage vor
dem ende des bundeswehreinsatzes rund
300 personen nach deutschland in
sicherheit bringen können das ganze ist
dann kurzfristig gescheitert wie es
heißt dann streitigkeiten über pässen
und visa bei der frage wer dafür
verantwortlich ist wird im moment im
dreieck von außen innen und
verteidigungsministerium hinter den
kulissen jeweils mit dem finger auf
andere gezeigt und zusätzlich werden
dann noch nebelkerzen geworfen
beispielsweise bei der frage wer sich
wie lange gesperrt hat das
aufnahmeverfahren zu vereinfachen als
sicher gilt die afghanischen stellen
waren mitschuld hätten auf reisepässen
bestanden verantwortungsübernahme ist
offensichtlich mitten im wahlkampf kaum
einfacher als sonst im leben
gut einen monat ist die flutkatastrophe
in rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen jetzt her mindestens
190 menschen verloren dabei ihr leben
tausende häuser sind zerstört
jetzt hat die bundesregierung einen
wiederaufbau von auf den weg gebracht 30
milliarden euro von bund und ländern
geld das auch im rheinland pfälzischen
ahrtal dringend gebraucht wird von dort
berichtet angela eppert
cornelia schlosser steht buchstäblich
vor dem nichts bis vor wenigen tagen
befand sich hier in schuld ihre bäckerei
mit wohnhaus jetzt alles abgerissen
dabei hatten sie gleich nach der flut
versucht die schlammmassen aus dem haus
zu bringen doch die mauern zogen das
wasser auf wie ein schwamm nichts zu
retten
im aartal spricht man von 8800
zerstörten häusern brücken strassen
schienen kommen dazu
auch im betrieb von heizungs und
sanitärinstallateur markus sebastian in
mayschoß stand das hochwasser bis in den
ersten stock lager und büroräume
verwüstet nicht mehr zu benutzen ich
schätze mal schon dass wir hier in den
gebäuden drei bis 10.000 euro schaden
haben und ich hoffe dass wir das
irgendwie gestellt bekommen schön wäre
es natürlich da auch mit unterstützung
vom staat auch cornelia schlosser wie
ihre bäckerei hier wieder neu aufbauen
mit wie viel geld sie planen kann weil
sie noch nicht sie hofft dass das gros
des entstandenen schadens von ihrer
versicherung abgedeckt wird und der rest
aus dem fluthilfe von der
bundesregierung aufgestockt wird wenn
die ämter jetzt da ich jetzt mal voran
machen und man hat vielleicht die ideen
die man hat die kann man schon mit
einbringen 100 geht dann also ein
bisschen zäh vonstatten
dann kommt man vielleicht noch schaffen
der aufbau von der bundesregierung ein
stück hoffnung für die menschen im
aartal
und jetzt der blick auf die korona
zahlen die steigen mittlerweile wieder
deutlich schneller als gründe nennt das
robert-koch-institut zu wenige impfungen
die ansteckende hre delta variante die
reisezeit und das ende der schulferien
jürgen kehl mit einzelheiten
die korona instanzen kennen seit anfang
juli nur eine richtung wieder nach oben
gestern registrierte das robert koch
institut mehr als 8.300 neue fälle die
inzidenz aktuell 40,8 vor einer woche
waren es noch knapp 5000 neuinfektionen
incidents 25,1 auffällig besonders hohe
werte finden sich auch dort wo die
sommerferien vorbei sind und wieder mehr
getestet wird der törn flensburg hamburg
oder rostock das im tempo bleibt eher
schleppend aktuell sind 57,8 prozent der
menschen in deutschland zwei mal geimpft
die über 60-jährigen liegt mit 82,5
prozent ganz vorne für die zwölf- bis
17-jährigen gibt es erst seit vogel
sondern eine impfempfehlung die quote
hier 16 prozent
mehrere bundesländer haben oder planen
spezielle impfaktionen für diese
altersgruppe auch an schulen schließlich
gehen die sommerferien nach und nach zu
ende für mehr als zwei millionen
schülerinnen und schüler war es heute in
nordrhein westfalen so weit über den
start ins neue corona schuljahr
berichtet dort die fahrbahn
nicht alle kommen gleichzeitig der
versetzte schulbeginn ist inzwischen
normalität an dieser düsseldorfer
gesamtschule genau wie die tests zu
schuljahresbeginn hier jetzt täglich
egal mit welchen umständen wie ich in
der schule sitzen dürfen ich bin dankbar
dafür aber weiß auf jeden fall dass es
schüler gibt die sich schon geimpft
haben uns wurde gesagt dass man in den
schulen jetzt bald auch ein empfang
gebot bekommt immer angebote für
schülerinnen und schüler ab zwölf jahren
düsseldorf will in bestimmten schulen
impfen köln setzt auf mobile impft teams
lehrkräfte seien nach eigenen angaben
bereits zu 90 prozent geimpft weniger
getan hat sich beim thema luftfilter
hier sind sie zwar beantragt aber es
fehle noch die förderrichtlinie
schulstart mit offenem fenster wie
gehabt das lüften bleibt das a und o
nicht nur im sommer sondern auch im
winter weil es ist das
mittel was nach wie vor angewendet
werden muss trotz maske trotz
entsprechenden anderen schutzmaßnahmen
schuljahresbeginn mit einer gewissen
corona routine alle hoffen sich hier auf
dauerhaften präsenzunterricht aber es
bleiben zweifel
komplett entspannt bin ich nicht wir
sind auch auf szenarien wie wechseln
unterricht distanz unterricht
vorbereitet ich hoffe ihr sehr im
interesse der schülerinnen und schüler
dass das nicht realisiert werden muss
schulstart in nordrhein westfalen mit
gemischten gefühlen und dem dreiklang
testen impfen lüften
die innenminister der eu haben in einer
telefonkonferenz über das immer
schwierigere verhältnis zum belarus
beraten seit monaten missbraucht
diktator lukaschenko flüchtlinge aus
krisenländern als druckmittel gegen die
eu eine staatliche fluglinie hat bereits
tausende flüchtlinge aus dem irak und
weiteren krisenstaaten nach belarus
ausgeflogen dort werden sie richtung eu
geschickt über die grenze etwa nach
polen oder nach litauen gerd rybak
energy sitzt den bagdad sein bruder in
belarus das vermeintliche tor zur eu es
für seine familie eine sackgasse
wir waren fünf tage im niemandsland
bekamen kein essen hat mit einer und
ausschlafen und nicht mit
buy back er laufen videos ein der bruder
filmt einen weg gefährten
rechts litauen belarus die menschen
dazwischen spielbälle im niemandsland
bei diesem zwischenfall drängen hinten
die grenze aus belarus vorne bremsen
polizisten aus litauen das kleine eu
land wirft dem nachbarn dem machthaber
alexander lukaschenko schon lange vor
der benutzer flüchtlinge als waffen
beim video treffen der innenminister
holt sich liter und heute unterstützung
dass wir uns nicht erpressen lassen und
dass es völlig inakzeptabel ist dass
menschen dazu eingesetzt werden um
erpresserische politik zu betreiben und
so traf sich heute der präsident des
europaparlaments mit der opposition von
belarus die eu zeigt haltung aber die
rechnung zahlen auch die flüchtlinge bei
kerner john lebt in sorge um die familie
ich rate meinen bruder dass er es weiter
versuchen soll in die insel zu kommen
nie wieder zurückzukehren denn hier hat
er keine zweite chance der irak hat die
flüge nun vorerst ausgesetzt auf druck
der eu
erst kam das erdbeben dann tropensturm
grace in haiti steigt die zahl der
todesopfer weiter auf jetzt fast 2000
außerdem wurden etwa 10.000 menschen
verletzt in dem bitterarmen land
gestalten sich die such und
rettungsarbeiten vier tage nach dem
erdbeben schwierig auch weil besonders
betroffene orte nachdem stunden über
spenden sind
zurück nach europa von der extremen
hitze in der mittelmeerregion ist auch
frankreich betroffen im süden des landes
starben bei waldbränden zwei menschen im
hinterland von profi kämpft die
feuerwehr seit tagen gegen die flammen
7000 hektar land sind bereits abgebrannt
etwas 10.000 einwohner und touristen
mussten in
notunterkünften untergebracht werden
und jetzt der sport da hat das
tennisspiel von angelique kerber freude
gebracht knapp zwei wochen vor den us
open zeigt sich deutschlands beste
tennisspielerin in topform beim wta
turnier in cincinnati besiegte sie die
weltranglisten fünfte liga süd olina mit
22 einsätzen cincinnati sid eine
kämpferische angelique kerber gewählt
die angstgegnerin endlich wieder
zuschlagen variabel ihr spiel und
risikoreich ein stopp zum 4 2 im ersten
satz und nach vielen verpassten
gelegenheiten endlich der satzgewinn 7
zu 5 ein mentaler kraftakt den sie nicht
durchhalten kann gegen die nummer sechs
der welt braucht sie eine auszeit musste
im zweiten satz 2 zu 6 verloren geben um
im entscheidenden dritten wieder voll da
zu sein matchball nach über zwei stunden
und als philo die naz ball ins aus geht
hat angelique kerber sie nach sieben
niederlagen zum ersten mal wieder
besiegt
gestern abend in dortmund der 3 2 1 sieg
der münchner im supercup gegen den bvb
der rekordmeister feiert seinen ersten
sieg der saison und der neue
bayern-trainer julia nagelsmann der
möchte jetzt ein titel hamster sein die
freude über den ersten sieg mit seinen
bayern entlockt ihm sogar etwas
selbstironie ich habe ja auch so kleine
hamster zähne ich würde gern einen titel
hamster sein die führung der bayern
verdient genau brief land und
lewandowski köpft unhaltbar 41 10 minute
dann lewandowski mit dem blick für
müller das 2 2 04 minuten nach der pause
machte es den bayern dann beim dritte
tor zu einfach wieder lewandowski ganz
cool 31
ich denke einfach nochmal das ist ein
gutes spiel von beiden mannschaften
waren die bayern
herzlichen glückwunsch main konnte so
richtig über die eigene mannschaft
freuen konnte er sich nur bei diesem
traumtor von marco reus am ende
bekanntlich zu wenig es feiern die
bayern
das war es von sport dankeschön fehlen
noch die lottozahlen die gewinnzahlen
lauten 7 22 25 27
43 48 und die superzahl 6 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
das wetter bringt ein bisschen regen
aber auch mal sonne die details hat
gleich katja honnefer marietta slomka
begrüßte im heute journal um viertel vor
zehn wir danken für ihr interesse
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
sturmtief luciano ist nach nordosten
abgezogen und hat die schwüle hitze
weiter nach osten abgedrängt so gab es
temperaturen von 40 grad jetzt
eigentlich nur noch hier richtung ural
ähnlich warm wurde es auch in andalusien
in spanien mit 38 grad die nacht wird er
kühl zumindest in bayern sinken die
werte auf elf bis neun grad sonst werden
16 bis 12 grad erreichen es gibt häufig
viele wolken und ab und zu fällt etwas
regen im norden und im westen
deutschlands etwas regen fällt auch
morgen noch vor allen dingen in der
westhälfte bleibt es eher trüb
freundlicher sieht aus wie an der
nordsee und am nachmittag kommt vor
allen dingen auch in süddeutschland
häufiger die sonne zum vorschein
die temperaturen sind sich überall recht
ähnlich sie liegen zwischen 18 grad im
bergischen land oder im sauerland
genauso wie auf den ostfriesischen
inseln und bis zu 23 grad am oberrhein
in den nächsten tagen geht es von tag zu
tag aufwärts mit den temperaturen am
freitag regnet es noch in der
nordosthälfte der samstag wird dann ein
schöner august tag mit viel sonnenschein
und temperaturen von 19 bis 29 grad am
sonntag drohen von westen gewitter guten
abend